The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on George RR
Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words, it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
One of the most popular Targaryens in history
and definitely the best warrior House Targaryen
ever produced is Aemon the Dragonknight, the
grandson of Rhaenyra Targaryen.
The Dragonknight has been referred to as the
noblest and greatest knight that ever lived
and his skills with a sword were legendary
throughout Westeros.
Prince Aemon Targaryen, also known as the
Dragonknight, was a prince of the Targaryen
dynasty
and the second son of King Viserys II Targaryen
and grandson of Rhaenyra Targaryen who fought
in the Dance of the Dragons. Aemon joined
the Kingsguard during the reign of his uncle,
King Aegon III Targaryen, son of Rhaenyra,
at the age of seventeen, and eventually rose
to become Lord Commander. After Aegon III,
Aemon served four other kings.
He died saving the life of his brother, King
Aegon IV Targaryen.
Prince Aemon has been referred to as the noblest
knight who ever lived,
and his skill with a sword is legendary throughout
the Seven Kingdoms.
Even over a hundred years after his death,
he is a popular figure among the highborn
and smallfolk in songs, stories, and fables.
Aemon became known as the Dragonknight
because the crest on his helm was a three-headed
dragon of House Targaryen wrought in white
gold.
As an infant, Aemon was large and strong,
and just as beautiful as his brother Aegon
was.
A dragon's egg was placed in his cradle. All
rejoiced at his birth, except his older brother
Aegon,
who was found by their mother hitting the
newborn Aemon with Aemon's egg.
Aemon was inseparable from his sister Naerys
when they were young.
Stories speak of Aemon's doomed love for his
sister. Aemon and Naerys supposedly loved
each other. According to the singers, both
Aemon and Naerys cried the day Naerys married
Aegon in 153 AC, although historians report
that Naerys had only cried during the bedding,
while Aemon had quarreled with Aegon at the
wedding feast.
He became a great jouster and swordsman later
in life.
The Dragonknight grew to be so accomplished
in the lists and with the sword that he was
deemed worthy of carrying the Valyrian steel
sword Dark Sister. Shortly after Naerys and
Aegon's wedding, Aemon joined the Kingsguard,
taking his vows at the age of seventeen during
the reign of his uncle,
King Aegon III Targaryen known as the Dragonbane.
During his life, Aemon would serve under five
kings: his uncle Aegon III, his cousins Daeron
I and Baelor I, his father Viserys II, and
lastly his brother Aegon IV.
Aemon once fought Lord Cregan Stark. Prince
Aemon claimed he never faced a finer swordsman.
Cregan Stark, who fought for Rhaenyra during
the Targaryen civil war,
considered Aemon to have been the best swordsman
he ever faced as well.
The fight between the two happened shortly
before the Conquest of Dorne began.
The Dragonknight was around 20 and the Wolf
of Winterfell was around 50.
Why did Cregan fight a grandson of a woman,
Rhaenyra Targaryen,
for whom he fought in the Dance of the Dragons,
you may ask.
While the exact circumstances of this event
remain yet unknown,
I can tell you that Starks and Targaryens
were the closest of allies in this time period,
so Cregan and Aemon's fight was either a sparring
duel or they fought in a tourney.
This would be the second time Cregan visited
Kings Landing,
the first time being in the Dance of the Dragons
when he ruled Kings Landing
in the event that came to be known as the
Hour of the Wolf.
He came to Kings Landing bringing his son
and heir Rickon
as well as the northern army with him to join
King Daeron the Young Dragon in his Conquest
of Dorne.
Cregan’s son and heir Rickon accompanied
Aemon (in Daeron I’s army) for the Conquest
of Dorne.
Rickon Stark fought bravely and died in this
conquest.
During the invasion of Dorne, Aemon prevented
an assassination attempt on the Young Dragon
by throwing himself in the path of a poisoned
arrow meant for his king.
Aemon survived the poison and was sent back
to King's Landing to recover.
Upon his recovery Aemon returned to Dorne
to protect his king
and won great fame by defeating a Dornish
champion. A rebellion in Dorne undid Daeron's
conquest, however. Aemon was with Daeron when
he met the Dornishmen under a peace banner
in 161 AC, together with four other knights
of the Kingsguard. However, in betrayal, the
Dornishmen attacked Daeron and his knights.
The Young Dragon died with Blackfyre in his
hand, surrounded by a dozen enemies. Three
of those Kingsguard knights died defending
Daeron, one shamefully yielded,
and Aemon the Dragonknight was captured after
slaying two of the betrayers.
Lord Wyl of Wyl eventually put Aemon naked
in a crow cage placed above a pit filled with
vipers.
The new king, Baelor I Targaryen, made peace
with the Prince of Dorne.
On his return trip from Sunspear, Baelor tried
to free his cousin Aemon.
House Wyl was told to release Aemon into Baelor's
custody,
but instead, they gave Baelor the key of the
cage and an invitation to use it.
The Dragonknight, fearing for his cousin and
new king's safety, begged Baelor to leave
him,
but Baelor refused and walked into the pit.
Singers say the snakes bowed their heads
and refused to bite Baelor due to protection
from the gods. However, some maesters believe
Baelor was bitten six times before reaching
Aemon's cage, while Dornishmen claim the king
was bitten half a hundred times before using
the key. The freed Aemon carried Baelor upon
his back,
while the Wyls wagered on how long they would
last.
The venom put Baelor in a coma, so Aemon carried
the comatose king north.
The cousins arrived at Blackhaven, where the
castle's maester treated Baelor.
The king eventually awoke upon the journey
to Storm's End,
but it was half a year more before he was
fit to travel to King's Landing.
Aemon served during the brief reign of his
father Viserys II Targaryen, king from 171
AC to 172 AC.
Aemon's elder brother, Aegon IV, succeeded
their father, Viserys II.
During Aegon's reign, Aemon remained the Lord
Commander of the Kingsguard,
a position he held until his death. When Naerys
was accused of adultery and treason by Ser
Morgil, Prince Aemon defended his sister's
honor in trial by combat and slew Morgil.
This inspired many songs and furthered Aemon's
renown, much to King Aegon's annoyance.
Rumors remained about Aemon being the actual
father of Aegon's son and heir, Prince Daeron.
This caused several people to look at one
of Aegon's bastards, Daemon Blackfyre,
as the new heir to the throne. The truth of
these rumors have never been proven or disproven.
Disguised as a mystery knight, Prince Aemon
once won a tourney after his brother Aegon
had forbidden him to take part, because Aegon
wanted to crown his mistress of that time
as the queen of love and beauty. Disguised
as the Knight of Tears, Aemon won the tournament
and named Naerys Targaryen in place of the
mistress. Despite Aegon's feelings of disrespect
and hatred towards Aemon and Aegon's provocations,
Aemon died honorably, defending his brother
and king against the assassination attempt
by two brothers of House Toyne
who sought revenge for the torture and execution
of their brother, Ser Terrence Toyne.
Queen Naerys grieved Aemon's death and died
in childbirth a year later.
King Aegon IV did little to honor the Dragonknight's
memory.
Aegon began to make barely-veiled references
to his son Daeron's alleged illegitimacy,
something he only dared to do because both
Naerys and Aemon were dead.
Aegon's attempts to blacken his brother's
name failed,
as Aemon is remembered as a heroic figure
on par with legends of the Age of Heroes
and his memory greatly respected throughout
Westeros,
while the king was posthumously dubbed Aegon
the Unworthy.
Daeron II, Aemon's nephew (or son, according
to rumors),
named his grandson Maester Aemon Targaryen
in honor of the Dragonknight.
Aemon the Dragonknight will definitely be
one of my favorite characters in the House
of the Dragon, although his time will come
in the later seasons of the show.
An honorable man who not only upholds his
oath to his brother and King Aegon the Unworthy
even upon the worst of insults, but also dies
to save his life.
The noblest knight that ever lived and the
best warrior of his time,
and likely the best warrior in the history
of Westeros.
Legendary characters such as Aemon the Dragonknight
and a dozen more legendary characters coming
before and after him, legendary battles such
as the Conquest of Dorne
and many more coming before and after as well,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, House of the Dragon, brings
in 2022 on HBO.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and I hope
to see you in the next one.
Peace!